it's part of the secret sauce in your
big mac
the condiment in your reuben
it's creamy yet tangy zesty
and named after a breathtaking part of
new york state i'm talking about
thousand island dressing the origin of
thousand island dressing traces back to
the highest ranks of american society
how did it all come to be
well that's where things get interesting
two tales lie at the heart of the
thousand island dressing dispute
there is alan benus former owner of the
thousand island inn where he claims the
dressing was first served to the public
and then there's george bolt a legendary
hotelier whose chef created the dressing
and had it served at his hotels we
tracked down a george bolt expert to
explain his story george bolt was a
prussian immigrant he rose to one of the
most prominent hotel men of the nation
he also loved to vacation in the
thousand islands
one day mr boat and his wife louise were
taking a boat ride on one of their
yachts and the chef on board forgot
salad dressing so he improvised and
created what became to be known as
thousand allen dressing he loved the
dressing so much he began serving it at
the wall of astoria hotel in new york
city but according to the other guy alan
bienis it's nothing but hearsay the
dressing was originated by the wife of a
clayton fishing guide named sophia
lalone she gave the recipe to the
original owners of the hotel where it
was first served to the dining public
after we purchased the hotel and going
through
looking at everything in the safe was a
sheet of paper with a recipe on it and i
wasn't sure what it was i took it out to
our kitchen staff and
the head cook said it looks to me like a
recipe for thousand islands dressing
so will we ever learn the truth
nothing is more popular than competing
legends
or as delicious
[Music]
you